have you ever played a game and just
thought to yourself wow that was a truly
unique experience and as the years go on
and games progress you can't help
wondering how much better would that
game be if it were attempted again today
game mechanics are basically features
that make a game tick it's now become
common practice for games to have
mechanics such as health objectives
level up or skill tree systems however
even though games are only getting
bigger and more complex by the year some
game mechanics have either been replaced
or lost to time and it's these forgotten
gems that I would like to explore with
you today so let's go back to the good
old days of Gaming
flightjacking
siren is well known in the horror genre
as a classic for many reasons it was
able to successfully provide the player
with an overwhelming sense of
vulnerability as it successfully Blended
traditional Western horror film
techniques with more subtle
psychological themes which are iconic to
Japanese horror the game's dark
environments and vulnerable characters
and really eerie sounds had me terrified
when I played as a child but one game
mechanic stood out from the rest
sidechecking sightjacking allowed
players to literally look through the
eyes of the shabito that were trying to
kill them
this added a totally unique perspective
to the horror genre in video games as it
allowed the player a glimpse into what
the shabito could see in here which was
often drowned out by really disturbing
groans but through their Vision the
player could also spot themselves
displayed as a glint on the screen the
larger the glint the closer they were to
the shabito that they were sightjacking
however when sight checking the player
character is left completely vulnerable
to any attack which just adds an extra
layer of fear to an already
overwhelmingly terrifying game as
someone who really enjoys horror games
but it's also very scared of them this
pushed me out of my comfort zone forcing
me to get close to what I was afraid of
in order to use it to my advantage I'd
love to see what games could do with
this concept now seeing as it's been
over a decade since the last Siren game
released back in 2008 memo systems
Gregory horror show is a not so
well-known horror game however it became
something of a cult classic to those who
had the luck of stumbling across it
myself included the game centered around
a hotel which was slowly filled with
guests
who wanted to harm you in the worst way
possible
death the player's goal was to steal the
souls of these guests in order for them
to escape the hotel however they had to
do this without being caught first the
only way to do this was to learn the
routines and weaknesses of the guests to
use to your advantage and as you might
expect stealth is a pivotal aspect of
the game now eavesdropping is not a
unique concept within the gaming World
however using it alongside the game's
memo system rewards the player for their
patients sneaking when the player Begins
the game they're presented with a book
full of empty time slots for each guest
this suggests the times when these
guests will be occupied doing a certain
task to reveal what the guests are doing
Within These time slots the player can
eavesdrop on them to listen to a thought
dialogue in its entirety
these tasks repeat daily allowing the
player a chance to discover what the
guests are up to at each time slot until
they have discovered enough information
through the thought dialogues to
retrieve their next soul and progress to
the next level the benefit to this is
not only discoverability but it's also
the ability to track where each
dangerous guest will be by simply
looking at your memo the more sneaking
the player does the better the payoff
the concept of peering through keyholes
and listening in on NPC conversations
still happens quite regularly in games
today however using it with this system
allows a way for users to retain the
information that they learn as well as
influencing gameplay especially when the
game revolves around stealth and
avoiding characters as someone who loves
to admire the details of games and will
actively go out of my way to learn as
much about the Games characters as I can
this concept naturally makes me really
excited I want to learn the daily
routines of a game's characters
especially in a way that can influence
gameplay so I want to play a game like
this again even if it doesn't have an
oddly aroused Pink Lizard
time for a blood test
oh this is
so good
[Music]
random events
random events in my opinion is something
that got explored a lot around the
PlayStation 2 era and started to fizzle
out in favor of more open World Games
with branching narratives sticking to
the horror theme
Eternal Darkness sanity's Requiem has a
sanity system that triggers random
events whenever the player sanity gets
low these events are varied including
having your inventory appear empty
having fake enemies surrounding you
having your character grow or Shrink or
even having their head fall off and
recite Hamlet
some random events only occur at certain
chapters within the game which makes
this mechanic an integral part of the
game's discoverability and replayability
thump Hill also had some effective uses
of random events which left players on
their toes wondering if danger was
really ahead of them
of course most times in horror games an
atmosphere will build up around a player
to cause suspense with audio and visuals
whenever they are about to face
something that is made to scare them
however Silent Hill 2 incorporates
random scare events such as
unintelligible Whispers in rooms or even
a doorknob rattling on the other side of
the door when really there is nothing
there technically for a player to fear
[Music]
do you hear this
having random events causes the player
to not always trust the game that
they're playing which might not work
well for all games but for these
examples it really created the sense of
anxiousness that is needed to elevate
the fear within a horror game very much
like the unreliable narrator technique
in books if done well this can create
some really memorable and unique
experiences if anybody is brave enough
to try and pull it off
hidden choices
talking of Silent Hill 2 I'd also like
to talk about its use of subtle player
choices that influenced its many
different endings nowadays many games
offer player agency by giving the player
choices throughout the game's narrative
however these choices are more often
than not made very obvious to the player
through either a dialogue choice or a
QuickTime event narratively driven games
such as life is strange and telltale's
games will put these choices on screen
for the player to choose from and more
often than not they would also flag to
let the players know when a choice will
be pivotal to the game's narrative
Direction and ending during Silent Hill
2 however the game logs the small
actions that would depict the natural
play style of the player and this is
what influences the game's ending uh Sun
Hill 2 spoilers if if that's still a
thing some examples are triggering an
underwater ending if a player depicts
risky Behavior by taking in lots of
damage and not healing very often which
shows James's lack of respect for his
own life a good ending which is
influenced by many things including
reading a letter from James's wife Mary
my wrestler stream
and the Maria ending if a player
actively gives a lot of attention to the
character of Maria who is a seductive
portrayal of James's wife Mary actions
like defending her from monsters and
checking on her when she decides to stay
in a hotel room all add up to getting
that ending allowing players to
influence A Game's narrative makes for a
personalized experience and also adds
some replayability by making these
choices very obvious to the player it
informs them of the importance of this
choice and the impact that it could
possibly have on the game World however
I feel like the downside to offering
this much information to a player is
that it could possibly break immersion
allowing them the time to think
logically about their choices instead of
doing what feels natural which in my
opinion would allow for more interesting
results if we take away this information
and allow players to act on impulse
instead of over analyzing every choice
they're about to make then perhaps
players could learn a little bit more
about themselves along the way I did try
and do kind of a demo of this in my game
Perfection on itch IO where I analyze
play Styles characteristic synopsis is
patients curious about their environment
they proved somewhat curious but
remained focused that sounds like her
yes feel free to check it out Link in
the description no problem
fixed camera angles fixed camera angles
used to be a staple in the horror genre
due to the technical limitations of the
time however as games have progressed
and these limitations are no longer a
concern we saw them replaced with more
favorable camera views such as Express
person or third person
in many ways this is a positive thing
because it allows more immersion for the
player to have control over the camera
and what they can see
however I can't help but miss the fear
that came with not knowing what was
beyond the bounds of the fixed camera
angle games like Resident Evil and alone
in the dark utilize this lack of player
control to their advantage by
handcrafting what a player could see and
when this would often heighten scary
scenes such as Monster reveals and also
bring attention to important items it's
allowed for Creative camera cutaways
that helped environmental storytelling
in ways that we could not recreate with
a more modern first-person camera view
for example this shot in alone in the
dark the new nightmare when the player
runs in front of a mansion and suddenly
sees the camera switch to show someone
watching them from within the building
there are many benefits to giving full
control to the player over the camera
especially in regards to gameplay
however through doing so we lose the
ability to hand craft these moments that
have been so memorable within the
history of the horror game genre and I
would love to see what games could do
with it today and if you want to hear
more I do discuss it in depth on my
video All About fixed camera angles and
the Forgotten horrors of them
personalized events similar to Hidden
choices are personalized events where a
game would take either a player's
actions they had already taken through
the game or even their own information
and utilize this to create personalized
experiences
Metal Gear Solid is highly praised for
its groundbreaking design that paved the
way for a new genre of stealth games
however this wasn't the only mechanic
that was remembered for its Ingenuity
the boss battle the psychomantis
subverted player Expectations by using
their own gameplay and data against them
like Silent Hill 2 the game had been
subtly tracking player actions but
instead of using this to affect an
ending psychomantis would actually relay
this back to the player through their
dialogue
[Music]
psychomantis would also famously quote
on any saved Konami games that the
players had on their memory cards
[Music]
I understand it's more difficult now to
derive Player information especially in
a time where games are made to be
cross-platform however I'd love to see
what information games could pull from
an Xbox account or PlayStation or steam
to create these truly fourth wall
breaking moments imagine seeing your
profile picture framed in the game or
perhaps one of the NPCs or possible
enemies has one of your friends user
tags from steam or wherever else human
AI combat
it's common for a player to run into
different enemy types in a game that all
have varying levels of difficulty and
combat Styles perhaps one NPC is slow
moving and has a shield to protect their
front from a distance while another is
fast moving and goes straight in for the
attack however both of these NPCs have
one thing in common and that is no
matter their combat style they will stay
within the player's vicinity Condemned
criminal Origins introduced a whole new
style of combat for its NPCs when it was
released in 2015 that I can only
describe as being human these enemies
are deranged criminals that have
definitely taken a little hit or
something funky and the game's melee
combat system forces the player to get
up close and uncomfortable with them but
what has stuck with me the most is their
unique writing style instead of running
at the player to attack them the player
would instead hear them first and upon
getting closer then catch a glimpse of
them running off through the many doors
or blown out holes of the environment
some would even attempt to hide in the
room to catch you off guard
and this alongside the mainly melee
combat really kept the player on guard
at all times one iconic part of the game
was within a shopping mall which was
filled with Christmas decorations
shattered display cases and of course
mannequins instead of running away here
some enemies would stand still in the
hopes that they would blend in with the
many mannequins dotted around the wide
open spaces there they would wait
patiently to see if a player would get
close enough to get a jump on them
understandably this made players
distrust any mannequins they came across
and forced them to scan any room they
entered looking for suspicious figures
that could be a frozen enemy in Disguise
something about realizing a shape in
front of me was actually an enemy
waiting to attack me was seriously
unnerving as so often it took a while
for the details to present themselves
through the darkness and give way to the
figures for nature I'd stand there
watching them watching me and nothing
has quite creeped me out in that way
since
immersive skill progression
skill trees are a pivotal part of player
progression in RPGs as they allow for
players to invest in particular skills
that then enhance their preferred play
style these skill trees are usually
available within the game's menu where a
player can assign skill points once they
have been unlocked through leveling this
manual process gives the players
visibility over the many possible Paths
of the skill tree so they can make an
informed decision on where to use their
skill points however in the past there
have been games that try a more
immersive approach to progressing
through these skill trees bethesda's RPG
games such as Morrowind and Oblivion
focus on assigning skill points to
in-game actions weapons and objects and
due to this skill points would progress
due to the player's natural play style
for instance running would improve
Athletics and using a bow would improve
Marksmanship players could also read
books or paid trainers as an alternative
method of improving these skills
huh
in 2006 Ubisoft released a horse riding
simulator called pepper funnel take the
reins which allowed players to
experience being a student in a
prestigious horse riding school where
they could progress their skills through
choosing which horse training classes or
other activities they would like to
allocate time to throughout the week
each class or activity would enhance a
skill and Aid toward the game's
narrative as well as weekly competitions
there were classes aimed at improving
horse care as well as skills such as
show jumping or dressage as well as
activities such as visiting the restroom
which enhance the player's social status
as well as allowing the player to
develop relationships with their fellow
students this replicated a school
setting where students are expected to
juggle classes and social time as well
as creating a layer of strategy by
forcing players to allocate their time
wisely players need to care for their
horse and go to classes to do well in
the weekly competitions as well as go to
social activities to progress the game's
overall story I'd like to see how this
idea of immersive skill progression
could be pushed even further today and
while we're on the subject I would also
like to see more horse games and no I'm
not talking about horses in games not
from where you vouch
I want more horsey games play style
affecting the world maybe not the best
title but it's all I could come up with
player agency is an important part of
bringing a player into a game world as
it allows the player control and
influence over the world itself this
arguably holds games apart from other
forms of entertainment such as films or
books whereby a consumer is simply a
passive viewer games introduce player
agency through interactable objects
cosmetic choices side quests and
basically anything that can be
influenced by the player lionhead's
Fable truly grasped this concept by
having many of its World Systems adapt
to the player's play style and
moment-to-moment choices it truly felt
like your actions had an impact on
Albion itself as the characters within
it would call you nicknames based on a
title you'd unlocked by doing certain
actions
stop
the most popular being Chicken Chaser
you heartless monster a player's
character themselves would also
cosmetically mirror their play Style by
depicting a more devilish or Angelic
form depending on how many good or bad
Deeds they'd performed and other
characters would react to this some
would see you and scream if you looked
like a demon whereas others actually
might prefer you that way
we'll make an excellent soldier in Fable
2 your character would also get visibly
henched if you increase their strength
stats too often there doesn't really
seem to be much repercussion in games
for a player's choices especially moral
moment-to-moment ones such as deciding
whether to steal or whether to attack an
innocent character or chicken NPC's
might reacts in the moment but once
that's over everyone kind of goes back
to their own business and acts like
nothing ever happened having the game
react to the player's actions and
decisions over time really elevates the
importance of the decisions that can be
made and just helps to make you feel
like you're actually having an impact in
the world around you so
a lot of game mechanics but we're not
finished yet because I got some special
mentions that I really wanted to mention
well yes that's why they're called
special mentions here are some less
specific game mechanics that I would
like to see more of in the future
couch Co-op as online multiplayer games
have become more and more popular
allowing multiple people to play from
the comfort of their homes on their own
PCS or consoles the need for split
screen has wavered however I still find
myself scouring through Xbox game pass
and steam to try and find a game that I
can sit down and play with my friends
while we're all in the same room but why
would I want to do that when we can just
play from the comfort of our rooms well
for starters it's cheaper you only have
to pay for one copy and you only have to
have one screen or console whatever it
is and also there's just something
magical about sharing your gaming
moments with your friends in person I
have so many fond memories of bonding
with family and friends over split
screen games such as Mario Kart and 007
and I want others to be able to
experience that as well and along with
split screen games also found other
really unique way is to allow people to
play games together on the same console
a game called kirakiri mix actually had
two character that could be separately
controlled by each half of the
PlayStation controller in its fast-paced
puzzle platformer and do not be duped by
these cute looking bunnies this game was
super hard and if you didn't have a
friend to share the controller with you
then you would just be rage quitting
it's a from software game so what do you
expect
call me old-fashioned but I really like
to get some friends together grab some
snacks get some drinks and play games on
one screen in the same room and as games
move more towards online multiplayer
there's just less and less options for
us to play there was once a time when
you would buy a pre-owned Game and hope
that when you opened it up you'd find a
small scrap of paper this paper would
indicate a rare find that all Gamers of
the 2000s and earlier were eager to
learn cheat codes
cheat codes were a wonderful way for
both players and developers to Simply
have some fun it afforded some mystery
around the game and got people talking
about possible cheat codes that could
help make your game easier unlock
different parts of the game or even
trigger Secrets such as the fisheye lens
view in The Sims it's a shame that the
word cheat now alludes to players
ruining the game for other people or
hacking it for themselves when back in
the day devs used to have fun with these
cheat codes and would put in little
secrets for anyone who had the Curiosity
to seek them out game booklets okay
these are not game mechanics no but I
really wanted to include this one as
well game booklets used to be a really
good way to introduce a player into a
game world without them even having to
insert a disc or hit play these booklets
not only gave players valuable
information such as the controls for the
game but they also introduced The Game's
narrative through colorfully worded
character bios and pictures as a child I
remember reading them fondly especially
when my mum would pick up a game at this
store and I was reading it in the back
of the car on the way home and I would
also use it to check up on the controls
if I didn't want to have to pause the
game to see them some booklets would
even have Maps within them that players
would leave open in front of them while
playing the game so they didn't have to
keep pulling up the in-game map and this
would really help with immersion again
this could just be Nostalgia talking but
I do really miss having a physical
object that to build upon The Narrative
of the game world and lore but I do
understand that not having booklets is
slightly better for the environment so
maybe we could look into new approaches
to do this perhaps they could be stored
online and then there's a QR code that
you can scan and get access to it from
there or perhaps we could actually
incorporate it into the game itself like
they did in tunic and that is
a lot of game mechanics and special
mentions but I hope you enjoyed this
trip down my gaming Memory Lane maybe it
also unlocked some of your own gaming
memories as well as I was writing I just
kept on adding more game mechanics but
I'm sure there are so many more that I
have missed and as you can tell I'm kind
of biased towards horror games because
that is what I love so what game
mechanics aren't on this list that you
think really deserve to be do let me
know in the comments I'd love to hear
your thoughts and of course this whole
video was just my opinion you might hear
some of these game mechanics and go hell
no keep that in the past that is not fun
and that's perfectly fine we're all
individuals with our own likes and
dislikes but I do really like picking
apart what makes the game good to me and
why I liked it so I actually really
enjoy Aid making this video so thank you
so much to my patreons who actually
voted for this video topic because if it
wasn't for you I probably wouldn't be
doing this video I'd probably be doing
another Unreal Engine tutorial which I
will be doing more of in the future
don't you worry
um but yeah
um much appreciate everything that you
do all of your supports if you want to
say thank you there's a little thank you
button down here somewhere in YouTube
and uh of course you could also join the
patreon as well links in the description
but I think that is enough for me so um
I will see you in my next YouTube video
uh you can catch me on twitch.tv where I
stream way more often if you for some
reason want to hear more of my voice
keep analyzing games and uh have a
lovely day everything bye
let's go back to the good old days of
gaming in my day we had PlayStation one
and two darling
Okay so